>> Bret: BREAKING TONIGHT,
CONCERNS OVER THE DELTA VARIANT
AND WHAT IS HAPPENING WITH THE
POSSIBILITY OF BOOSTER SHOTS NOT
ONLY FOR THE IMMUNE COMPROMISED
BUT POSSIBLY FOR EVERYBODY.
IS THAT ON THE FRONT BURNER?
LET'S BRING IN DR. FRANCIS
COLLINS DIRECTOR OF THE NATIONAL
INSTITUTES OF HEALTH.
THANK YOU, SIR, FOR BEING HERE.
>> GLAD TO BE WITH YOU AND TO
TALK ABOUT THESE THINGS, BRET.
>> Bret: YEAH, IT'S IMPORTANT,
PEOPLE HAVE A LOT OF QUESTIONS,
PETER REFERENCED IT IN HIS
PIECE.
IT WAS AN AXIOS PIECE THAT WAS
TITLED BY THIS BIG COVID
CHALLENGE FADING VACCINES MAY
DEMAND BOOSTERS.
HERE IS HOW THEY QUOTE IT I
THINK EVERYBODY BELIEVES THIS
WEAKEN WANES OVER TIME TO WHAT
EXTENT.
BIDEN OFFICIAL.
HAMSTRUNG BY EXTREME LACK OF
CLEAR DATA FROM THE CDC.
EVEN TOP ADMINISTRATION
OFFICIALS CAN'T GET THE
INFORMATION THEY WANT MAKING IT
HARDER TO ASSESS WHEN BOOSTERS
WILL BE NEEDED AND FOR WHOM.
THE VACCINES ARE STILL HAVING A
POSITIVE EFFECT BUT WE'RE
PAINTING THIS TRAIN AS IT'S
GOING 180 MILES AN HOUR SAID
MICHAEL OWESSER HOME DIRECTOR OF
CENTER FOR DISEASE RESEARCH AND
POLICY.
SO ARE YOU CONFIDENT THAT THESE
VACCINES CAN LAST BEYOND SIX
MONTHS?
>> THEY HOOK GOOD UP UNTIL SIX
MONTHS LET'S BE CLEAR ABOUT THAT
LOTS OF DATA TO SHOW EVEN SIX
MONTHS HOSPITALIZATION 90%.
THAT'S ALL GOOD.
DELTA HAS THROWN ANOTHER WRINKLE
IN HERE.
WE HAVE NO LOOK AND SEE WITH
DELTA NOW BECOMING THE VAST
MAJORITY OF VIRUS IN THE U.S. IS
THAT GOING TO AFFECT THE WAY IN
WHICH THIS SLOW WANING OF IMMUNE
RESPONSE IS GOING TO BE
NECESSARY TO ADDRESS?
I CAN ASSURE YOU AND EVERYBODY
WATCHING THAT THIS IS A TOPIC OF
INTENSE DAILY INVESTIGATION BY
THE FDA, THE CDC, THE NIH AND
OTHERS TRYING TO ASSESS WHAT'S
THE RIGHT DECISION TO MAKE.
AS OF RIGHT NOW IT LOOKS AS IF
EVEN WITH DELTA, OUR CURRENT
VACCINES ARE HOLDING UP REALLY
WELL.
WATCH THIS SPACE.
WEIGH ARE GOING TO BE CHECKING
THIS VERY, VERY FREQUENTLY OVER
THE NEXT FEW WEEKS.
>> Bret: RIGHT NOW A BOOSTER FOR
SOMEONE WHO IS IMMUNOCOMPROMISED
BUT POSSIBILITY THAT WE ALL GET
BOOSTERS COME THE FALL?
>> WELL, I'M GLAD YOU MENTIONED
THE IMMUNOCOMPROMISED.
CLEARLY WE DO WANT TO HELP THOSE
FOLKS WHO HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO
RAISE ADEQUATE IMMUNE RESPONSE
FROM THE STANDARD DOSING AND
THERE IS CLEARLY AN EFFORT TO
TRY MAKE THAT POSSIBLE ASAP.
THAT IS A SEPARATE CIRCUMSTANCE.
THOSE AREN'T PEOPLE WHO SORT OF
NEED A BOOSTER AFTER SIX MONTHS.
THEY'RE PEOPLE WHOSE INITIAL
IMMUNIZATION DIDN'T QUITE TAKE.
FOR THE REST OF US.
WELL, MAYBE THIS FALL.
I THINK ALL OF US LOOKING AT THE
DATA WILL SAY BOOSTERS ARE GOING
TO BE NECESSARY AT SOME POINT
THE QUESTION IS WHAT'S THE RIGHT
TIMING THAT'S WHAT WE ARE
LOOKING TO TRY TO DEFINE FROM
THE MOST RIGOROUS SCIENCE WE CAN
GET OUR HANDS ON.
>> Bret: SEEMS LIKE A LITTLE
FRUSTRATION GETTING THE DATA AT
LEAST PRIVATELY FROM THE POLICY
MAKERS.
BUT, CAN YOU DEFINITIVELY SAY TO
SOMEBODY THAT THE VACCINE
PROVIDES BETTER PROTECTION THAN
THE ANTIBODIES THAT YOU GET FROM
ACTUALLY HAVING HAD COVID-19?
>> YES, BRET.
I CAN SAY THAT THERE WAS A STUDY
PUBLISHED BY CDC JUST 10 DAYS
AGO IN KENTUCKY.
AND THEY LOOKED SPECIFICALLY AT
PEOPLE WHO HAD HAD NATURAL
INFECTION AND PEOPLE WHO HAD
BEEN VACCINATED AND THEN ENDED
UP GETTING INFECTED AGAIN.
SO WHAT WAS THE PROTECTION
LEVEL?
IT WAS MORE THAN TWO FOLD PEOPLE
HAD THE VACCINE IN TERMS OF
PROTECTION THAN PEOPLE HAD THE
NATURAL INFECTION.
THAT'S VERY CLEAR IN THAT
KENTUCKY STUDY.
THAT SUR SURPRISES PEOPLE.
KIND OF SURPRISED ME THAT THE
VACCINE WOULD ACTUALLY BE BETTER
THAN NATURAL INFECTION BUT IF
YOU THINK ABOUT IT, IT KIND OF
MAKES SENSE OF THE NATURAL
INFECTION KIND OF GETS INTO YOUR
NOSE AND AIRWAY.
THE SYSTEMIC VACCINE GETS MORE
OF YOUR IMMUNE SYSTEM ENGAGED
AND APPARENTLY DOES A BETTER JOB
OF PREPARING YOU IF YOU ARE
GOING TO SEE THAT VIRUS AGAIN.
THAT'S SEATTLEED ISSUE.
>> Bret: YOU SAID THAT'S DATA
FROM ALL OVER, INCLUDING
OVERSEAS.
THE "WALL STREET JOURNAL" CITES
THE U.K. DATA.
LATEST SURGE OF U.K. CASES IN
U.K. GIVING GROWING OPTIMISM THE
TRANSMISSIBLE VARIANT OF THE
COVES CAN BE HELD AT BAY WITH
HIGH LEVELS OF VACCINATION AND
PUBLIC CAUTION.
ALTHOUGH CASE LOADS ARE NOW
TICKING HIGHER, HOSPITAL
ADMISSIONS HAVE BEEN FALLING,
DEATHS ARE A FRACTION OF THE
LEVEL SEEN IN EARLIER PHASES OF
THE PANDEMIC.
IN OTHER WORDS, THE U.K., OTHER
PLACES HAVE SEEN A MAJOR SPIKE
BUT THAT IS REALLY FALLING OFF
AS TIME GOES ON.
IS THAT WHAT WE ARE TO LOOK
FORWARD TO?
>> WELL, ONE WOULD HOPE.
I THINK IT'S HARD TOKES TRAP
PLATE FROM OTHER COUNTRIES'
EXPERIENCE.
I'M A LITTLE CONCERNED.
WHEN I SAW THE U.K. SPIKE COME
DOWN FAIRLY QUICKLY I WAS
ENCOURAGED.
LOOK AT THE LAST WEEK OR SO IT
STOPPED GOING DOWN AND IT LOOKS
LIKE IT MIGHT BE GOING BACK UP
AGAIN.
THIS VIRUS HAS SO MANY TRICKS
THAT WE HAVEN'T COMPLETELY
FIGURED OUT.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS, BRET, IF WE
IN THE UNITED STATES WANT TO
AVOID MORE CASES, MORE
HOSPITALIZATIONS, NO DEATHS IF
THERE WAS EVER A WAKE-UP CALL
FOR THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE NOT
GOTTEN VACCINATED YET, THIS IS
THE MOMENT, FIND OUT HOW TO GET
THAT VACCINE THERE IS A PLACE
NEAR YOU THAT HAS IT READY.
IT'S FREE, IT'S AVAILABLE.
THERE IS NO TIME TO WAIT.
>> Bret: WE PUT THAT UP EVERY
DAY, DR. COLLINS.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Bret: LAST THING, AS MORE AND
MORE INFORMATION COMES OUT, I
REMEMBER YOUR SKEPTICISM IN THE
EMAILS YOU SENT DR. FAUCI AT THE
BEGINNING AND WE HAVE GONE OVER
THAT WEANED HAVE ASKED YOU ABOUT
IT ABOUT THE COVID ORIGINS AND
THE SKEPTICISM ABOUT IT COMING
FROM THE LAB AND YOU CLARIFIED
THAT YOU THOUGHT IT WAS NOT A
WEAPONIZED THING FROM THE
CHINESE BUT THAT IT MAY HAVE
BEEN A LAB ACCIDENT.
IT SEEMS MORE AND MORE POINTING
THAT WAY.
ARE YOU CONFIDENT SAYING THAT OR
CLOSER TO THAT?
>> I DON'T THINK I HAVE ANY MORE
NEW INFORMATION TO BE ABLE TO
TIP THE BALANCE.
CERTAINLY POSSIBLE THAT THIS WAS
SOMEHOW UNDERSTUDY IN THE LAB
EVEN THOUGH IT WAS NOT HUMAN
ENGINEERED FROM SCRATCH.
I'M QUITE CONFIDENT OF THAT BUT
HOW DO WE KNOW THE YESES OR NOS?
I HAVE LOOKED AT THE REPORT,
CERTAINLY FROM THE HOUSE
COMMITTEE.
I THINK WE ARE ALL WAITING IN
THE NEXT TWO WEEKS TO HEAR WHAT
THE NATIONAL INTELLIGENCE STUDY
IS GOING TO COME UP WITH.
WE HAVE COOPERATED WITH THEM.
WE HAVE ANSWERED LOTS OF THEIR
QUESTIONS, GIVEN THEM LOTS OF
TECHNICAL ADVICE, I'M NOT PRIVY
TO WHAT THEIR CONCLUSION IS
GOING TO BE.